here to explain much more we go to bill
hammer he's at the big board again
tonight bill a lot going on yeah sean
good evening to you listen to trey's
reporting and bring a little bit of life
to you on the map behind us here about
what we're happening they did have these
talks earlier today and the russians
offered these humanitarian uh corridors
for folks in kiev and sumi and kharkiv
and mirapool to allow them to leave the
problem is a lot of those roots as trey
mentioned they led to russia or belarus
and that was simply a non-starter this
story down here on mario paul is really
it's staggering when you think about it
this is a battle now sean has been going
on for well over a week uh there's no
power uh they're running very low in
medicine there are reports about
operations being conducted without
anesthesia there's no phone service
people wandering around this town asking
people if they know so and so who knows
so and so is related to a family member
across town are they still alive the
ukrainians describe the fighting in this
town as medieval
now sean when i left you on friday night
you know we talked about the russian
forces coming out of crimea and they got
as far as the town of mikolav and it
seems over the last 48 hours yes there
is progress for the russian army in the
south but there is limited progress over
the past 48 hours and that was noted at
the pentagon as well not a lot of action
on odessa just yet remember this is
moldova moldova's here and this is
transnistria now okay keep that in mind
there are at least 1500 what moscow
calls peacekeepers 1500 troops in this
little strip of moldova you can see what
they're trying to do sean they're trying
to link up the southern route here and
if you close off the black sea the
economy what's left of it today anyway
in ukraine is shut off from the rest of
the world so we'll watch that story also
up in the northern part here near the
capital city i think a couple
developments here see this little shaded
area sean here with the red and white
stripe
it's largely countryside and
segments of the russian army have moved
west
from their location toward the capital
city of kiev so you're going to have a
look they don't hold the ground here but
again there's been very little
resistance for the ukrainian army easy
for the russians to move we're watching
this development up here i'd watch this
little sliver down here talked about
that nuclear plant from last week uh
where there's another nuclear plant just
north of this little location we've uh
uh we've denoted here on the map uh talk
about escape routes how do you get out
of here right sean
everything in yellow is a train
everything in blue is a roadway sean you
were talking about erpine a moment ago
that was last week over the weekend
where you had
two adults and two children who were
killed by a russian bomb that hit them
they were trying to make their way on
this road to get on this train and come
in to keep as an escape route uh the
other town is up here in the northwest i
remember last week we had that drone
video of that town
if you want to take that road out of
town you have to go through an air
that's been absolutely leveled and
devastated by the russian army and you
ask yourself why you're living in fear
right now uh based on some of the
reports here sean on
friday you wanted to know
how far the city center is from erpine
it's 16 miles you wanted to know how far
the airport is from the city center it's
roughly 20 miles this we believe now is
the route of the convoy that is still
stationary 40 miles to the north and
west and it is still there and the
pentagon said today they believe there
are no tanks necessarily in this uh this
convoy but it is supply vehicles that
was destined you think now for the
airport which was the original idea for
the russian military invade the country
take the airport bring the troops in
from the north and establish your base
at the airport to this day on day 12
sean that has not happened for moscow
day 13 tomorrow bill let me ask you one
more question on the convoy because it's
important
i can't really
understand a why the convoy stationary
has not been taken out and b why they're
not moving um it doesn't make sense to
me any insight i agree with you on that
uh i think there are 10 different
theories just like there was a week ago
what i am told is that a lot of these
drones from turkey the tb2
um
it is it is thought that they are
running low in supply and perhaps
they're even out because if you can do
an armed drone in the air you could take
out that convoy this afternoon or even
tomorrow but that hasn't been the case
uh so that that's one theory on the case
uh the other idea on behalf of the
russian military was well
how would you get 40 miles of vehicles
all stacked up there was some reporting
over the weekend that suggested these
were different military units that got
backed up on the highway because they
had problems with their equipment or
they ran out of fuel or they needed more
food and supplies and one group is
running into the other which really
gives you a bit of imagination right now
for how this russian military can or
cannot operate
well it's good
watching this one thing unfold if they
make it to keeve in my view i hope pray
i'm wrong it would be a massacre if they
get taken out it would be a huge win for
the ukrainian side and this they seem to
be sitting ducks why that hasn't
happened i guess is anybody's guess
sean if you want to hear something
interesting just you're going to be
locked into this when it happens okay
when kiev is under siege you're going to
want to know a lot about this capital
city it's a nipper river it's like their
mighty mississippi okay it is wide there
are there's a number of bridges that
cross the west side of this river that's
really the historic area that was built
up the east side is more residential but
if you blow these bridges
and you're the russian army you got to
come from both sides to take the town
there is no other way to do it in that
case sean hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else